he's the voice of college football for
ESPN ABC and also tennis host for the
mothership as well Chris Fowler on the
program good morning Chris how are you
hi Dan I'm well I'm very very blissful
very relaxed this morning so I've done
my eye breathing exercises which is a
daily ritual and quarantines I'm relaxed
don't don't talk too loudly or too
quickly and don't you know don't be
angry at controversial and will do just
find the sport okay
that's the mattress I assure you it's a
natural high do you watch any college
football replays or anything is it doing
it for you I mean I watched the Texas
USC game Rose Bowl classic game which I
stood on the sidelines and watched Vince
Young run to the pylon and was the
greatest game I've ever seen so when
ESPN ran that the other week I did watch
it I have not been dialed into the
classic games I know people are starving
for it and that's able to fill the void
for them it's not doing it for me
I am missing live sports maybe not as
much as some people as much as I thought
I was but I am not glued to youtube or
ESPN Classic locked in I'm probably
shouldn't say that but I don't know I I
probably will watch some went a vintage
Wimbledon when it gets around
bumble that I'll be missing that
obviously if we don't start a football
on time I'll be I'll be starting for it
I'll probably be I'll probably watch LSU
comes in ten times but I haven't done a
lot of that yet all right let's jump
into it then you mentioned that we're 20
Saturdays away from the scheduled start
of college football and you threw out
some questions there you also said
informed speculation here so where do
you want to start with the college
football season well people are all over
the place there's no consensus just like
when you hear the experts differ on how
to deal with this virus going forward
there's no two people on the same page
in college football the commissioners
are having these regular conversations
the coaches are doing their thing
each athletic director has its own take
depending on where they are in the
country so we're not going to know a lot
for a while I think Larry will begin to
happen during may but
I just don't get the sense that the
country is going to be in the same place
and these programs these conferences are
going to be at the same place in late
July August when you absolutely have to
get players back on campus if you're
going to play it it's not what people
want to hear but I think there's severe
challenges trying to start a season on
time and if you don't do that
like what's and everybody won that's
what you have for God we hope for things
but if hope isn't a strategy unless you
got truth and facts right we've already
seen that so what's realistic and I
don't know if it's really realistic to
gather in 20 Saturdays and have a
national season I mean you could have a
lot of colleges online exclusively the
summer the campuses won't even be open
so I can you bring this unpaid workforce
back in there and say hey we're playing
games without a bunch of people going
wait why are we what do we do is this
there's a lot of questions and not very
many answers right the idea of a delayed
season even even a season early in 21 in
the spring which seems radical to people
to others find it just undoable but it
might be a way to salvage football in
the calendar or the school year I should
say if it can't be salvaged in the fall
informed speculation inform speculation
on what in particular you were talking
about well what what's likely going to
happen I mean what are the challenges to
getting things up and running on time if
there are a lot of them I mean do you
think this is in the same place in New
York in California in Louisiana in Texas
and Ohio in Pennsylvania in Florida Utah
I mean we're all over the place you know
with this this this virus is cresting in
different places different places in the
cycle I mean you know the South really
hasn't been hit yet but do you think
there's going to be states that are
spared people are viewing this in the
lens of where they are and not realize
they look 50 governors don't have to
sign off for football to come back and
I've been told that not every single
athletic director and commissioner has
to be exactly on the same page but what
if one area of the country is
totally different from another but if
the West is ready to open up quicker but
the the northeast of the Big Ten isn't I
mean what are you gonna do you can have
a parcel season it doesn't make any
sense to me so I mean I know that
there's going to be no perfect solution
Danny and I know that people go crazy
when they think that we can't wait until
February or March but if you need the
revenue if you operate under the
assumption that these these conferences
have got to get on the field at some
point or revenue loss is going to be
catastrophic to the whole athletic
department not just football
then you're not dealing with ideal
scenarios are dealing with desperation
and trying to make it work that's why
he's Chris Fowler
the voice of college football for ESPN
and ABC I'm also wondering though Chris
do we minimize the regular season and
maybe try to maximize postseason and and
that we do make that leap from Final
Four to eight or 16 everything's on the
table everything's on the table because
these are such uncharted times
nobody knows what's what's the best
thing to do if you if you start the
season late let's say you're not going
to be ready August you start the season
in October November you cut some games
you you alter the postseason I don't
think it's going to be thirty bowl games
played under a lot of these scenarios
but the playoffs what's important that's
where the dollars are in the big bowls
so yeah you can shorten the season you
can do away with the non-conference
that's been talked about so everything's
been talked about a lot of all this is
on the table but I don't know I mean you
know the conversations are going on in
other sports or even more radical what's
going on in college football just in the
desperation to have a baseball season
what they're talking about what the NHL
is contemplating the NFL is going to get
heavy political pressure to start on
time and operate normally and you know a
lot of these owners will feel the
financial pinch believe it or not I mean
they're all super wealthy but you take
away that revenue they're going to feel
the pinch if they don't have a season on
time the network's will apply their
pressure the NFL is far less complicated
than college football though nothing is
as complicated in getting everybody
together and up and running is college
football I mean it's just if there's
central control yeah and that's that's
part of the problem a lot of cases yeah
that's my big big concern here is you
don't have that one voice you know Adam
silver with the NBA Rob Manfred with
baseball Roger Goodell with the NFL and
then you get to college football you go
to see well that's what's going on
you're having the power of five
commissioners who are not the deciders
but they're the ones that have to get
together and run the scenarios and be
ready for whatever is decided but you
know they tell me you know the the
municipalities the states they're the
ones who shut things down and they're
the ones that are turning things back on
and so you've got to listen to you know
the governors and the mayors of cities
like San Francisco and New York and
Chicago and Dallas and those are the
ones that are going to decide that you
know this state's you know this battle
back and forth you see play out at these
briefings the last couple of days I mean
the states are saying wait a minute we
decided what's right for us in the
cities in fact specifically we're going
to decide what's right for us going
forward and and that's the way it's
going to be so that's what I that's why
I started with how are you going to be
on the same page who knows what it's
going to be like when the state's not
yet affected really begin to to build in
these numbers you know well then you
have damage a rush to get back on the
field and then a lot of coaches are just
saying stuff that are tone-deaf
so wait you're the one that has to
breathe you're the one that was in a
zen-like mood now you're like you're
getting a little riled up here then you
have you know Mike Gundy and then you
have Davos Sweeney's words you know they
they throw this out we're coming back
and like some somehow he can the
coronavirus doesn't affect us or we're
coming back May 1st and I went we can't
have these proclamations here we can't
go wrong no you can't and I think that
that's the thing though that the coaches
are paid to be ready for any scenario
and they have to plan and get ready for
an on-time season because that's that's
the first scenario that's on the table
is unlikely to some people is that seems
that's what you have to plan prior I
talked to a bunch of coaches I'm going
to do
another video on what kinds of programs
are going to be able to come through
this in thrive and what programs are
really going to struggle what does it
take within the program to to weather
this and so and try to get their
opinions it's obvious that they are
preparing for an on-time season like you
have see when you have to be hopeful and
optimistic that's what coaches are but
you also have to have perspective and
and a sense of priorities and these are
not pro athletes man and if your campus
is closed if your campus has said it's
not ready we're not ready for students
to come back but football players get
your butts back in we'll put you in
quarantine we'll take your temperature
every day you're going to prepare to go
out and perform so we can get this cash
cow flowing again wait a minute I mean
don't you think a lot of players are
going to say wait a minute we won't do
that you're deciding for us a public
health issue when the rest of everybody
else is operating on different rules I
know they want to play I get it and they
feel invulnerable Dan you know that
there's no segment of society it feels
more bulletproof more able to withstand
something than males age 18 to 22 right
I mean that's the age group that's going
to feel like we were not high risk we're
not going to get sick and we get
symptoms you're going to kick it to ass
okay I understand that's your mindset
but this is so new and unique and
unknowable that he's just on the side of
caution and safety it's an unpaid
workforce for once let's not take him
for granted and let's consider their
needs that just makes sense yeah I get
it and you're right you know 18 through
22 you're like hey I'm gonna live
forever but you know the reason why in
history those are the people that you
put out the fight or wars you know
because they're the ones that'll jump
into the fray and and be fearless and
feel like it's not going to happen to
them hey I wonder - no I wanted to ask
you this for I let you go you hand out
the Heisman every year and yeah you know
Joe burrow wanted obviously but what
strikes you about his personality
extreme confidence I have never run into
anybody's cocky
let's just say it and it's okay because
he wouldn't backed it up in the meetings
before the championship game Kirk and I
both came out again I have never seen a
guy or a team with more supreme belief
they're going to kick the ass of a
really good team the defending chance at
120 some in a rose defense and defense
coordinator have these proven
credentials
Jill burrow had absolutely zero doubt
that that name was going to unfold
exactly as it did and I thought wow man
and that's a leader I know that he's not
that way when you walk around him in
everyday life could she put him in game
mode and he was very much in game mode
in this meeting and he walks on the
field with supreme belief so I know what
people think he's overrated not worthy
of a top pick got his limitations to is
better I promise you in his head and his
heart he believes there's nobody better
than him and he'll believe it he's ready
from day one and I don't think there's
anything wrong with that at that
position I that's what strikes me about
him he is you know I thought also he's
like a 40 year old soul and getting much
younger by super super mature very
bright so all those things that are
gonna wow the teams are there if if two
it was healthy and you saw them both
you're the Bengals who would you take
you have to be questioned I mean I'm not
in that position team teams have flunked
those questions for years I mean to to
to or throws a prettier ball I mean to -
it's watching him throw the ball in
person for the first time is one of
those wow moments like I've never seen
the ball come out of a guy's hand it's
beautiful hmm Joe doesn't throw like
that he just doesn't he throws in hit
those great ball to get me wrong but I
mean a lot of his his spirals are not
tight they're not spun they're there
they get there he's an incredibly
instinctive and incredibly accurate
thrower but you know what what struck me
when I watched it in person was he not
as pretty of authority
cause I thought but he's way more
athletic burro is quick he's faster than
you think he's elusive he's instinctive
all those things are hard to quantify in
a workout but - or throwing the ball and
workout and I know that hip thing is
something I'd be a little bit concerned
about I mean you say a hundred percent
but can you be sure
wow you know most guys had that surgery
end up having hip replacement those are
normal people much less anything lasting
so somewhere in his future he's probably
going to have near an operation
hopefully it's after a long career but
man I hope he hope he's not pampered at
all by that but I just want to see him
it jus Sunday's throwing the ball the
way he throws his do you know that I
have Carson Palmer's Iseman in my man
cave dude yeah I just bought it at
auction no no he had it in his garage
and I said well if you're not using it
send it to me he packed it huh and sent
it so I have it in the man cave alone it
wasn't a permanent gift he might have to
come and get it he might have to come
and get it but he sent it I'm walking
around I have some like Heisman winners
only swag that I wear I thought that was
cool I don't have a trophy hey I know
hey great to talk to you I hope the
family is good my best to Jen and and
I'll be following you on Twitter Thank
You bud well Instagram who cares about
Twitter oh yes agree my band instead
instead send people to Instagram it's
much more it's much better for
quarantine you can expand untanned so
just I don't know I'm off Twitter I'm on
I'm on the instant Instagram Instagram
we'll do this again I enjoyed it be well
be all right thank you that's Chris
Fowler